the reasons behind their exclusions may
vary
but here's a look at some dceu
characters who all share a common thread
disappearing from a superhero mega
franchise without a trace
these are the characters who disappeared
without explanation
will smith's floyd lawton also known as
deadshot
is introduced in suicide squad as a
master marksman who never misses his
target
he's also shown to be a devoted father
to his daughter zoe
after being incarcerated deadshot is
recruited as a member of the
government-run suicide squad team
from there he helps defeat the film's
nefarious villain enchantress before
being put back in his prison cell
originally this was to be just the start
of deadshot's journey in the dceu
five months before suicide squad
premiered variety even reported that
smith was reprising his role as deadshot
in a sequel to the movie
by the end of that year various reports
noted that a spin-off movie about
deadshot was in development
in 2018 smith said they've been talking
about it
so if a good idea comes around we've
been having meetings but i would love to
i love deadshot in the years since
however there's been little word about
deadshot having any further presence in
the dc eu
reflecting his diminished status in this
franchise deadshot wasn't even
referenced in harley quinn's solo movie
birds of prey however there's still hope
for the character's return
according to variety after initial
attempts to recast the role
deadshot was written out of the upcoming
movie the suicide squad
but this isn't quite as bad as it sounds
according to sources
the decision was made in order to allow
smith the chance to reprise his role in
the future
for a good while it appeared that
deathstroke was poised to be a major
fixture in the dc eu
joe manganiello was cast in the role in
september 2016
intended to be the villain of ben
affleck's the batman a year later in
october 2017
gareth evans was in talks to write and
direct the solo deathstroke movie
starring manganello 2.
all of these developments occurred
before deathstroke made his first dc eu
appearance
in a post-credits scene for justice
league which teased him
teaming up with lex luthor to found the
legion of doom
unfortunately none of these plans for
deathstroke ever came to fruition
first affleck's version of the batman
fell apart matt reeves took over the
project and put together a new cast
which didn't include manganello
additionally the deathstroke solo movie
never got off the ground
in april 2020 evans described his
proposed deathstroke movie to yahoo
movies uk as
a lean story that would be kind of an
origin of that character
something that felt like it could be 100
minutes or 110 minutes long
max not to go over the two-hour period
with it
plans for another justice league movie
also never came to fruition
leading to no follow-up on that
deathstroke post-credits scene
currently there are no plans to have
deathstroke show up in any future dc eu
movies
in october 2019 manganello referenced
his troubled experiences with
deathstroke by telling comic book
resources
someday i'll write a book about it but
that time is
yeah among the military personnel
fixated on superman and man of steel
was general calvin swanwick played by
harry linux
swanwick proved a useful ally to
superman in the fight against general
zod
in his second appearance in batman vs
superman dawn of justice
the character had gone from being a
military general to united states
secretary of defense
linux's prominence in the franchise even
extended off the screen
at the 2013 san diego international
comic con
zack snyder had linux read a passage
from the dark knight returns
as a way of announcing that the
follow-up to man of steel
would pit batman against superman snyder
also planned to have swanwick become a
superhero himself in justice league
per the storyboards that zack snyder
shared on his vero account
swanwick was to eventually be revealed
as the cosmic being martian manhunter
these plans however never came to pass
after snyder was taken off justice
league
swanwick was left out of the film's
theatrical cut swanwick hasn't been seen
since batman vs
superman and no future dc eu movies have
announced plans to bring the character
back
in 2013's man of steel lawrence fishburn
appeared as the most recent cinematic
incarnation of the daily planet chief
perry white
for his take on the character fishburn
told comicbook.com that
essentially i used my model my
inspiration really is the late ed
bradley
who was a cbs correspondent on 60
minutes for many years
fishburn reprised the role in the second
entry in batman vs superman dawn of
justice
since that 2016 feature though
fishburn's perry white has been absent
from the dc eu
this is partially due to scheduling
conflicts on the part of fishberg
when asked to reprise the white role in
justice league fishburn declined the
offer
he later told the los angeles times they
asked me to come for a day but i
couldn't work it out schedule wise
and really what do you need the
newspaperman and justice league for
fish fishburn subsequently noted that he
wasn't sure about his future in the dc
eu
in 2018 he revealed to den of geek i
don't think i'm still on call
i was unfortunately unable to go do some
work on what turned out to be the
justice league movie
i don't know that i need to go back or
if they'll have me back or not
but i was grateful to have been a part
of it though a new superman adventure
could see the character returning for
now
the dceu's perry white appears to have
become yesterday's news
killer croc made his live-action movie
debut in suicide squad
in which he was portrayed by arawale
akanoye akbaje
a member of the titular group of
supervillains kroc managed to survive
the events of suicide squad
and ended the film with both a reduced
prison sentence and
access to bet in his jail cell however
unlike some of his fellow suicide squad
characters
killer croc will not be returning for
the next installment in the franchise
but this development seems to suit
akanoye akbaje just fine
he told yahoo movies uk i don't think i
need to do it again to be honest
i did it i enjoyed it it bought me a
bentley and i will keep moving on
killer croc being alive at the end of
suicide squad means the door is still
open for his return however
should any subsequent dc eu movies want
to further explore the character
for now though neither the dc eu nor
arawale akanoye akbaje is in a rush to
revisit the scaliest member of the
suicide squad
this is katana she's got my back she
cut all you in half with one sword
stroke just like mowing the lawn
okay yeah not the greatest intro in the
world
but katana showed some pretty
extraordinary superpowers in suicide
squad
especially when compared to the more
grounded skills of some of her teammates
even with those abilities though katana
ended up having a pretty small role in
the movie
this is primarily due to a number of her
scenes ending up on the cutting room
floor
including a sequence during which she
became possessed by enchantress and
attacked the other suicide squad members
sadly her reduced presence in suicide
squad ended up mirroring her subsequent
role in the entire dceu franchise
since her debut katana has been absent
from all of the dceu properties
including her team's follow-up movie
this is despite actress karen fukahara
having a clear vision of where she
wanted to take the character in future
movies
as she once told comicbook.com i'd like
to explore where she's from
what kind of training she comes from if
she gets a standalone movie that would
be awesome
there's so much story from the point of
her husband's death to her story leading
up to suicide squad
that's something that i'd love to show
on the screen unfortunately
though she may have rick flags back the
dc eu
doesn't have any plans to bring katana
back just yet
there are many superheroes in the dc eu
but none have the technological prowess
of cyborg
he made his full-fledged appearance as
part of the titular superhero team
in justice league after being introduced
to audiences
via cameo and batman vs superman
originally
the dc eu had big plans for cyborg which
included the character co-starring in an
early version of the flash movie
from there cyborg was supposed to get
his own solo movie entitled cyborg
which was set for an april 3rd 2020
release
booyah however those ambitions
ultimately went unfulfilled
since justice league in 2017 cyborg has
made no further appearances in the dc eu
ray fisher has said the lack of movement
for the solo cyborg movie is simply due
to money
he told cinema blend there's a ton of
people making those kinds of decisions
behind the scenes
and it would be a very very costly movie
to make because it is so cgi heavy with
cyborg
because i'm the only member of the
league that's not in a practical costume
you're going to be looking at 200
million just to make it
despite the character's absence from the
dc eu fischer hasn't given up hope on
playing cyborg again
fisher commented on the prospect of
reprising the role in a twitch live
stream by saying
nothing's off the table knock on wood
with no future appearances on the
horizon though
the most tech savvy dceu hero has for
now
been put in sleep mode prior to the
release of suicide squad
theories abounded about who ike baron
holtz was playing in the film
dr hugo strange was a particularly
popular guest
but if you're struggling to remember if
baron holtz was even in suicide
squad well it's because he wasn't
playing a famous comic book character at
all
in reality baron holtz ended up playing
a totally original character by the name
of hunter griggs
griggs was a sadistic prison guard at
belle reeve
taxed regarding the super villains that
would make up the suicide squad team
in the earliest scenes of the film he's
shown perpetrating particularly nasty
acts of abuse against deadshot and
harley quinn
eventually griggs is taken captive by
the joker
but at this point he pretty much
vanishes from the movie
you're so screwed what do you mean by
that
what do you mean by that get off harley
what do you mean by that
the audience has never shown greg's fate
and the dceu is apparently in no hurry
to clarify harley's statement
since suicide squad griggs has failed to
appear in any other dceu properties
and he isn't a part of the cast of the
suicide squad though pre-release
speculation ran rampant over who hunter
griggs was
it turns out the character wasn't all
that important to suicide squad
or for that matter the dceu at large
batman vs superman dawn of justice was
all about showdowns between superheroes
but it still had room for a super
villain that adversary was superman foe
lex luthor
here portrayed by jesse eisenberg the
man who orchestrated the titular duel
between batman and superman
luther is also responsible for creating
doomsday the creature that eventually
kills superman
by the end of batman vs superman luther
has been sent to prison
had his head shaved and delivered some
vague warnings to batman
indicating that he's aware of an
impending attack by darkseid
luther's final moments in batman vs
superman set up plenty of different
directions the character could go down
in future dc eu movies
however despite those cliffhangers the
dceu version of luther and his potential
connections to darkseid have been almost
totally ignored
he's only appeared once since batman vs
superman in a justice league
post-credits scene
to put it plainly
shouldn't we have a league of our own
in the years since justice league no
other dceu movies have even referenced
this particular super villain
and with no upcoming dceu movies
planning to end the character's absence
even eisenberg is doubtful he'll ever
return to the role of lex luthor
as he told movie webb i probably won't
do another
i don't know if they're making another
one where i would be in it
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one